Speaker 1: Let's now speak to the most important
people involved with the David Pakman show. Which
are the viewers without the viewers? I'm a
guy in a room with a microphone and it's sad
and it's disappointing. So we take calls via
discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
And today, we're going to start
with Jonah in Las Vegas. Jonah,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind?
Speaker 3: Hey, David, just wanted to know your
thoughts on the Nevada Senate race.
That is coming up. I'm from there,
so just interested to hear your thoughts.
Speaker 1: I haven't been following it,
to be honest. What's going on?
Speaker 3: The Republican. It was Trump's
number one big lie sort of conspirator in
the state. He was attorney general in 2018.
Speaker 1: Oh, Adam.
Speaker 3: Laxalt. That's right. Yeah. And it's
one of the closest Senate races. By the polls,
by the metrics, by professionals, whatever. Yeah.
Speaker 1: What I'm seeing is
that Catherine Cortez Masto
has overtaken Laxalt in the latest polls, even
though he had been leading. Is that correct?
Speaker 3: It's been back and forth throughout
the cycle. But yeah, regardless, it's going to be
incredibly close. I think Biden won by 2% and
she in her initial election also won by 2%.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and the polling actually seems
controversial because there's only two polls
from August. One has Cortez Masto up seven
and one has Adam Laxalt up three. I am not
a fan of Adam Laxalt. I think he's absolutely
horrifying and I support Cortez Masto there.
And I think that's an important race for people to
follow and get involved with. You can phone bank.
We don't want to give that one to Laxalt.
Speaker 3: Definitely.
Speaker 1: All right. Otherwise, Vegas is good.
Speaker 3: Yeah. I mean the they were hit
very hard by COVID, but with the service
industry. But yeah, it's all rolling back.
Speaker 1: Well, thanks,
Jonah. Great to speak to you.
Speaker 3: You, too.
Speaker 1: All right. There
is Jonah from Vegas with a reminder about a
very, very important race, that's for sure